video media 2 is in the telco space
and basically what we do is try to
connect the uk from our company
perspective what we're trying to do is
be more innovative that's the first
thing that was the first task like 12
months ago when we started this journey
and obviously
doing that in a way that was fast to
market so our delivery times weren't
really where they should where they
should be so our focus wasn't reducing
this lead time so we're quite ambitious
here what we want to do is to turn the
virgin meteo2 business into a tier one
tech company so i guess this is the
first step of that journey
and i just want to emphasize it's not
just about technology and also it's the
technology itself that affects what
people what people do and then how they
do it so i guess it ultimately affects
the the culture of the company as well
our solution uh i guess cuts across the
entire virgin medial to estate
we support like obviously millions of
customers in the united kingdom
and the the vision i guess is for any
customer focused data product is that
it doesn't matter like at which part all
the customer touch points are
consistent and attractive if you go 12
months ago in this organization we had a
four to six months lead time to make
critical changes in this algorithm and
right now where we are a couple of weeks
ago we were doing uh deployments uh in
under
in under 60 minutes uh and doing the
change doing the deployment uh doing the
testing and and putting live which is
just basically mind-blowing for where we
were before i can't thank you enough of
the google cloud team specifically with
the customer engineering team that
beatrice in that team and in the london
so
um not only they helped us with all
these questions that we asked but also
in many occasions they put us directly
in touch with the product engineering
team we are just two is is here in this
in this
award
is richard and i but to be honest there
is a big team of data engineers ml
engineers data scientists data analysts
data product managers so we have
a big team around and to be honest it
has been thanks to everybody right it's
not just basically to one particular
person so
we wouldn't be here as well if it wasn't
because of them and exactly i can't
agree more i think that's uh really
important uh that to emphasize that
without that team that at the backers
spoke at the back of that supporting us
this wouldn't be possible at all and
although
we are on the path or on the tracks of
trying to get to be a tier one tech
company but we're still enterprise so
the behind the scenes the complexity is
really really high and then we needed a
lot of support from you know the many
part of the business for us to achieve
this together we're very very proud
about winning this uh this award but at
the end of the day we're still
collaborating so it's not something that
has finished so i really appreciate
having the team there
by our side day by day and yeah very
grateful